In this problem, an existing sewer pipe
with an elliptical cross-section
measuring 19 in in vertical depth by 30
in in horizontal width is scheduled for
replacement. To maintain hydraulic
equivalency, the diameter in inches of
the replacement circular concrete pipe
that will most nearly convey the same
flow under full flow conditions is
18 in, 24 in, 32 in, or 48
in. So, this is a simple problem that
may even be too easy for the PE, but
it's one that I think is important to
remember how to solve for uh for anyone
who hasn't thought about it in a while.
So, we're being asked to find the
equivalent size circular pipe to replace
an existing elliptical one.
All we have to do is set an equation for
an ellipse equal to the equation of a
circle. If we search ellipse in the
reference manual, we can see that the
equation is just area=<unk>
* a *
[Music]
b. The only thing to note is that terms
a and b refer to the semi- major and
semi- minor axes rather than their full
lengths.
So in this case, a is going to be equal
to half of the width and b is going to
be equal to half of the
height. All we have to do now is plug in
the equation of the ellipse equal to the
equation of the circle and solve.
So pi * a *
b
equals if you need the equation of a
circle it's right underneath section
1.3.7.3 in 1.3.7.4
4. It's
pi
d^2 /
4. And substituting these terms, we can
see this is going to be w / 2 and b is
going to be h / 2. And that's still
going to be
equal to pi d^2 /
4. And finally, we can plug in our
unknowns from the equation. So our width
is 30 in. So, we're going to say p<unk>
* 30
in / 2 * the height of 19 in /
equ=<unk>
d^2 over
4. And if we want to simplify this even
more, we could cross
out 4 2
2<unk>i and
pi, leaving us with
just 30 in
* 19
in= d^2.
D will solve out to about
23 87 in which is closest to our answer
of 24 over here on the
left. If you forget to use the semi-
major axis and instead keep with terms A
and B, you will accidentally calculate
out closer to 48 in. So that's basically
the only thing you have to keep keep in
mind
here. So yeah, this is a quick problem
just meant to remind you of some
fundamentals and that's it.